he's a genius he's not a people person
but he's my kind of doctor house m.d.
you got to put the MD afterwards
otherwise people think you're talking
about a house no now house is one of the
few shows that I own all the seasons -
because it's just genius the house is
the story of a doctor who's a
diagnostician he gets all the weird
cases that no one else can figure out
and he solves them every week for you
and I guess they're based house on
Sherlock Holmes get it home house so he
just sees problems and he needs to fix
them he sees how things connect and if
he can't figure it out drives him insane
and he has his team of people and every
week they find a new case and they solve
it and it's a really interesting show
because first of all I like the
character like I said before the intro
he's not a people person he does not
care about the people he wants to solve
a puzzle there's actually an episode
where a guy dies and he never solves it
before he died and he did the autopsy to
figure out what it was that killed him
and he figured it out and he was all
good does not care about the people to
be fair he's not an he's a prick
it's different but it is part of his
personality granted he is damaged you
can't deny that and that really
plays in well when he works the clinic
yeah you know the clinic for people go
in with a stubbed toe and they want pain
meds and I think it's an emergency and
whatnot he cannot stand those people cuz
he's like they're overreacting their
immune systems gonna take care of the
flu that they have anyway why do I need
to be involved so it's kind of a
throwback to people like us who have
worked customer service if you've worked
customer service you want to see him
work the clinic because he tells them
what you've wanted to tell people for
years it's awesome warms my heart and
house has chronic leg pain which is kind
of a part of the stories I'm not gonna
ruin it for it but he needs to take
percocet to deal with it problem is now
he's an addict and addict doctor saving
people's lives yeah that shit's real
America now for me I really like seeing
house go head-to-head with someone like
in season one there's this guy who's his
big corporate guy he hates house he's
determined to get him out of there no
matter what the cause so house is like
sweet someone I get to conflict with I
thrive on that and personally I
understand that so see in house conflict
with this guy just brings me back to
working for some of my bosses oh yeah
gonna level with you
I love conflicting with upper management
like I said my kind of doctor now for me
what I like a show to do is change it up
every couple seasons it's a really
dangerous thing to do like why mess with
a good thing but you gotta do that to
keep the show feeling new this show has
done it a couple times and I like it
every time usually happens in a season
finale so I'm always like dude they
can't do that next seas
like it's not gonna be the same and to
show surprised me so in my book that is
some good writing right there the kind
of writing that I say it's worth
checking out and this show has a couple
of season finales blew my mind
actually season four was like the second
to the last episode that blew my mind
season finale season five hair on the
back of your neck standing up kind of
but I did like what he did in the
season finale a seventh that was good so
if you like crass people sarcastic
people who don't like people but they're
like geniuses who are so good at that
craft it's like ridiculous
I say check out house you're gonna like
it and yeah the show is seven seasons
long so that's pretty much me telling
you right now that you should watch
about a hundred feature films which
might make me an but I think
it's worth it so do you watch house do
you like those damaged geniuses are you
yourself a damaged genius we damaged
geniuses are a rare breed I know comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
and really losing my voice right now
it's all raspy I don't know why sounds
like Rachael Ray and that's my
salad